the media and the Democrats were
President Trump on illegal immigration
an NBA player talks about his white
privilege and Bernie Sanders act like a
front-runner i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show man it is such a
disparate news cycle I mean it's just
all over the place and we will get to
all of the various headlines you'll pick
the apples from the tree of news in just
a moment but first let me remind you
that in 2008 the u.s. national debt was
10 trillion dollars today the debt is
nearly 22 trillion dollars so we're
doing great guys it is rising like a
hockey stick if you don't think that
we're sitting on a house of cards then
you are living with your head in the
sand but since you're listening to my
podcast you are clearly smarter than the
average bear so what is your plan can
you afford another hit to your
retirement like the last downturn when
the S&P dropped 50% hedge against
inflation hedge against uncertainty and
instability with precious metals gold is
a safe haven against uncertainty my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be soo I'm not saying take all
your money out of the stock market put
it all in precious metals I'm saying
diversify like a smart person the
company I trust with precious metal
purchases is Birch gold group and right
now thanks to a little-known IRS tax law
you can even move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
and silver which is perfect for people
who want to protect their hard-earned
retirement savings from any future
geopolitical uncertainty if you look
back historically when the bottom falls
out of everything else gold does tend to
safeguard savings Birch gold group
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
contact Birch gold right now get a free
information kit on physical precious
metals see if diversifying into gold and
silver makes sense for you this
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move that IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds into a
precious metals IRA if that's something
you are interested in to get your no
cost no obligation kit text Ben - 47 47
47 again text Ben my name - 47 47 47 to
get more information again that is Ben -
47 47 47 and talks to my friends over at
Birch gold group okay so the big story
today is that President Trump continues
to be stymied on his immigration plans a
federal court has now blocked the Trump
administration from forcing asylum
seekers to remain in Mexico while
awaiting court hearings now this is not
really within the purview of the federal
courts the President does have enormous
power over border policy this is stuff
within the executive
inches per view this is really not stuff
within the judicial branch's purview
when it comes to the border that is a
foreign policy matter and that means
that the President does have exorbitant
and near to plenary power over what to
do with America's border situation and
the court doesn't just get to grant
rights to people who are coming across
the border without the president
enforcing those rights nonetheless a
federal judge again we have a bunch of
rogue courts across the country or
slapping national injunctions on the
federal government which really is an
act of judicial supremacy not judicial
review there's a difference judicial
review is the idea that the courts get
to look at the interpretation of the
Constitution and then they get to
determine whether a law is
constitutional or not but judicial
supremacy is the idea that the court is
the last best hope of the Constitution
of the United States and that the
president doesn't basically get to fight
with the courts and fight with the
legislature that the court is the
repository of all wisdom when it comes
to the Constitution and that is
something that was largely opposed by
Alexander Hamilton in Federalist 78 he
said that if the courts were disposed to
exercise will instead of judgment it
would defeat the purpose for them
existing their purpose is simply to
interpret the law as it is written it is
not to go above and beyond that and if
they do go above and beyond that their
opinion is of no more matter than the
president's opinion or legislators
opinion this is why the President and
legislators both take an oath of office
to uphold the Constitution if it were
really just kick everything over to the
Supreme Court you wouldn't need them to
swear those ODEs nonetheless Judah
judges across the country have decided
that they are actually legislators and
now a federal judge on Monday has
blocked an experimental Trump
administration policy requiring asylum
seekers to wait in Mexico while their
cases make their way through the u.s.
immigration court system a major blow to
president Trump's efforts to stem the
surge of crossings at the southern
border this is according to the
Washington Post US District Judge
Richard Seaborg and San Francisco
enjoined the migrant protection
protocols policy days after outgoing
Homeland Security Secretary Christian
Nielsen pledged to expand the program
the policy began in January at the San
Ysidro Port of Entry in California it
has been extended to Calexico and to the
entry in El Paso
Seaborg wrote that the approach would
have been further extended if the court
had not stepped in several hundred
migrants were returned to Mexico under
the program after seeking asylum at the
border why because once people enter the
country
then very often they don't show up for
their court dates or they show up for
their original court dates which merely
is just a way for them to kind of check
that box and then they figured that if
they show up for the original court date
and they wait six months they get an
automatic work visa and they can stay in
the country pretty much as long as they
want the percentage of people who are
actually deported after showing up for
court the first time is exorbitant
Leeloo
we had a mark Krikorian from the Center
for Immigration Studies yesterday on the
radio show he explained all of this in
detail there's a reason that people are
trying to get into the country and not
be held pending the judgment of their
Asylum on the other side of the border
because if they get here there's a good
shot that they are going to be caught
and then released into the general
population many of them will show up for
their first court hearing that first
court hearing is just to determine
whether or not they are criminals or
whether they are saying and then they
are released back into society at that
point all they have to do is wait out
that ticking clock if they wait for six
months they get an automatic work visa
and then they're off and running they
just overstayed the work visa and they
stick around in the United States this
by the way is the vast majority of
illegal immigrants both across the
Mexican border as well as into America
from other countries not across the
Mexican border the the overstaying of
work visas is the number one way that
illegal immigrants stay in the United
States the ruling is a preliminary
injunction at least temporarily stopping
the program and it paralyzes one of the
Trump administration's last remaining
tools to stem the flow of Central
American families trying to cross the
us-mexico border Trump took out some of
that frustration on the Department of
Homeland Security firing nearly everyone
in his 27 page ruling Seaborg said that
the legal question before him was not
whether the MPP is a wise intelligent or
humane policy or whether it is the best
approach for addressing the
circumstances the executive branch
contends it constitutes a crisis rather
he wrote the program probably violates
the Immigration and Nationality Act the
Administrative Procedures Act and other
legal protections to ensure that
immigrants are not returned to unduly
dangerous circumstances but there is no
actual evidence that returning
immigrants who are crossing over from
Mexico - Mexico - wait is putting them
in a newly dangerous circumstance in
Mexico is not Honduras or Guatemala or
El Salvador Justice Department officials
declined to comment on the ruling on
Monday the US government could appeal
the ruling to the Ninth Circuit they've
not indicated whether they will do so or
not this is
problem for the Trump administration is
the courts routinely stepping in and
overstepping their authority now the
Obama administration used to ignore
court orders on a fairly regular basis
with regard to for example the dreamers
so in a federal court in Texas struck
down president Trump's President Obama's
dreamers program Obama just ignored it
and continued handing out the papers to
people who are dreamers Trump could
theoretically do the same thing here and
you probably should because the fact is
there are a series of conflicting lower
court rulings none of them fit with each
other they're all over the place and
this is basically left the Trump
administration with no options advocates
for immigrants say the migrants are
fleeing poverty and violence in the in
Central America and should be allowed to
wait in - in the United States until
their cases are decided in the ruling
this judge Seaborg wrote the DHS will
still have the authority to detain
migrants when they return to the United
States he made clear his ruling does not
preclude Congress from creating an MPP
style program under federal law Trump
and top administration officials have
implored Congress to stop the flow of
tens of thousands of migrants every
month
Seaborg said to be clear the issue in
this case is not whether it be
permissible for Congress to authorize
DHS for attorney Lian's to Mexico
pending final determination as to their
admissibility so he is kicking it over
to Congress saying that Congress has to
pass a law specifically on this and
there can't be a regulation that does
all of this but that seems I think like
an overly narrow Mis reading of the
Administrative Procedures Act for one
the President does have tremendous
tremendous executive power in generating
regulations on all of these matters one
of the reasons the Christian Nielsen was
Christian Nielsen the Secretary of
Homeland Security was ousted from her
job was presumably because she did not
promulgate regulations quickly enough
for President Trump meanwhile there it
is important to note the level of
conflicts inside the federal courts over
all of this it is it is important to
really I think that when people when
people do not note that the federal
courts are all over the place on these
issues and legitimately
have not given any sort of comprehensive
opinion on what exactly the executive
branch can and cannot do that leaves the
executive branch without any way of
actually doing anything at all David
hora of Daniel Horowitz rather over at
conservative review has an excellent
piece on this
talking about exactly how all of these
courts are overstepping their boundaries
here's what he says this is rather than
categorically suspending immigration
requests at the border
the DHS issued a regulation in December
to continue claims but to have some of
the illegal aliens wait in Mexico
pending the outcome of the proceedings
statute is clear that the same way the
president can suspend all entry he can
place partial restrictions or conditions
on such entry this has been made clear
from for example president Trump's
travel ban in which the president simply
suspended immigration from particular
countries the judicial power vested in
the judge allows him to grant injunctive
relief to an American seeking protection
from a regulatory burden or criminal
prosecution a judge can say he will not
agree to punish a winning plaintiff even
if an executive policy or legislative
statute required it that is judicial
review a judge however has no such power
to issue an injunction to enable foreign
nationals to come into our country
without the permission of the president
of the United States and the fact is
that long-standing judicial history
suggests that the judiciary does not
have the power to make immigration
policy this way
Daniel Horowitz points out that there
are a bunch of California judges who
have ruled on immigration all of these
rulings are in conflict with one another
Dola G of the Central District of
California among many other radical
opinions overturned by the Supreme Court
said that the administration must
release all children after 20 days even
though the Florist settlement is
outdated and the statute downright
requires the opposite it is unclear
whether the president is allowed to keep
children together with parents or
whether the president has to separate
the children from the parents what
Democrats want is for the Flores
settlement to be held in place the
Flores settlement was a settlement
between the federal government and
plaintiffs led by the ACLU in which
federal courts basically green-lighted a
settlement during the Clinton
administration that said that children
have to be held in the most free
possible circumstances for a limited
period after that you have to separate
them from their parents and release them
into the general population this was
done with an eye toward releasing the
parents into the general population as
well Dana Sabra of the Southern District
of California has said that parents must
be released with children too which is
not I mean that's fully insane so that
she's saying that under American law you
must release parents with children so if
you cross the border with kids
then you will
under this particular ruling be released
into the general population we can't
hold you with the kids and we can't
separate you from the kids the only way
we can unify you with the kids is to
release you into the general population
that's not an immigration policy that's
a judge simply deciding what they want
to be the law Judge William Alsip of the
Northern District of California has
ruled that Obama's amnesty must remain
in place for now which is crazy
considering that Obama's amnesty was
never greenlit by Congress Judge John
Tiger of the Northern District of
California
just like Judge Seaborg ruled that the
administration cannot make a simple
common-sense regulation of driving
credible fear claims to point to the
entry even though the Immigration and
Naturalization Act states openly that
it's unlawful for any alien to depart
from or enter or attempted apart from or
enter the United States except under
reasonable rules regulations and orders
and subject to limitations and
exceptions as the president's may
president may prescribe Judge Edward
Chan of the Northern District of
California has ruled that temporary
protected status rather than being
temporary and discretionary is permanent
and mandatory for Trump I said that
Trump could not reject the so-called
DREAM Act because the fact is that
President Trump has quote-unquote animus
against non-white people none of this
has anything to do with the Constitution
none of this has anything to do with the
law and these judges are really
overstepping their boundaries and
providing Trump with not a lot of
options
so you're seeing Democrats come out and
rip president Trump supposedly for being
intolerant on the immigration issue are
being terrible on the immigration issue
dude has no options if you listen to
these courts he can't keep the kids with
the parents together because that
violates the rights of the kids he can't
separate the parents from the kids
because that violates the rights of the
kids and he can't even take the parents
and kids and say stay on the Mexican
side of the border so what's he supposed
to do that only leaves one option
release everybody which by the way is a
violation of American law you'll get two
more of this in just one second first an
alarming statistic for you over 75% of
americans are dangerously deficient in
omega-3 levels if you're experiencing
joint pain and chronic inflammation lack
of concentration weight gain chances are
you're probably one of these people no
matter your age height weight or gender
omega-3 fatty acids are vital to your
overall health they're considered a
useful pill by experts they're
clinically proven to improve mood memory
brain cardiovascular health many of the
top sellers simply do not contain an
Omega threes to notice therapeutic
results if you want to feel the benefits
instantly
what you need is Oh max three ultra-pure
it's the only game-changing omega-3
supplement on the market that is 94%
pure with a patented epa to DHA ratio of
four-to-one to fight unwanted joint
pains and inflammation Oh max 3 is
clinically tested certified sustainably
sourced it is 100% safe for you and your
family they guarantee it
Oh max is offering my listeners 50% off
a one month supply of Oh max three plus
free shipping and a 60 day money back
guarantee so you really have nothing to
lose just come to ol max health calm and
enter promo code Shapiro today take
advantage of this incredible savings
that is OMA X health calm today and her
promo code Shapiro for 50% off a
one-month supply you hear the hype
around Omega threes we'll give it a try
but Oh max health calm and enter code
Shapiro everyone can benefit from Oh max
3 go check it out right now
Oh max help calm enter promo code
Shapiro and meanwhile President Trump
being bashed about clubbed about the
head by the media and folks in the
democratic party for his temerity in
suggesting that perhaps he'll leave it
up to illegal immigrant parents what
they want to do with their children and
the president is supposedly considering
something that is being called binary
choice is according to the Washington
Post DHS officials are now looking for a
way to satisfy the president's demand
for tough measures including a plan
called binary choice that would give
migrant parents the option of remaining
detained as a family or agreeing to
separation so their children would not
remain in immigrant immigration custody
so in other words Trump is saying you
know you want there to be only one
option which is I release you and your
kids instead I'm gonna offer you the
option either you get to sign off on
staying with your kids in custody or you
sign off on your kids being separated
from you but there's no more of this
crap where we just release you into the
general population the goal of the plan
according to the Washington Post would
be to end the catch and release model
that has allowed most migrant families
to go free within the United States
while they wait to appear before an
immigration judge implementing binary
choice without lawmakers approval risks
another court injunction Stewart Baker a
top DHS advisor to George W Bush says
the president doesn't like the news he's
getting on immigration he's blamed
leadership at DHS this is not something
leadership at the department can fix
this needs to be fixed in Congress there
doesn't seem to be any appetite for that
well perhaps that's true perhaps that is
not but the fact is that the President
of the United States does have
normos amounts of power again over
immigration regulations and the courts
keep striking down every immigration
regulation when they spent years
basically okay and Barack Obama not
doing anything about illegal immigration
and actively seeking to incentivize
illegal immigration it's pretty
incredible
Trump has suggested two aids in recent
weeks that the administration's previous
policy of separating families at the
border could be used to deter crossings
and that a version of the policy could
be reinstated according to two people
with knowledge of the discussions some
aides have resisted the idea of family
separations citing the public backlash
last summer and noting that Trump
himself reversed it which is true my
President Trump was so intimidated by
the public backlash that he signed an
executive order saying that parents and
kids would have to be kept together
which generally resulted in the release
of the parents and the kids into the
general population of the United States
but with that said you know it is
amazing so it seems perfectly reasonable
to me like legitimately reasonable to
say to illegal immigrant parents listen
you're not getting released into the
general population many of you will show
up for your first time back to court and
then you'll disappear again we're not
gonna do that
you stay in custody until we've decided
whether your asylum claim is true or
fraudulent and it's your option either
your kids stay with your relatives while
you wait for your court date or they can
stay with you I don't see why that is in
any way inhumane or terrible the only
thing inhumane and terrible is Democrats
not providing the funding to allow some
sort of comfortable stay for the illegal
immigrants crossing the border with
their kids that's the only thing that
seems inhumane to me and the reason
Democrats are not doing that is because
they want to force the President to
release all of these people into the
interior of the United States they're
literally busing people into places like
San Antonio and dropping them off at
food at EDX I mean it's it's craziness
it's craziness nonetheless this has been
taken as evidence that the President of
the United States is a brutal horrible
terrible man now again Barack Obama kept
kids in cages in 2014 all of the
original pictures that were brought up a
couple of years ago were from the Obama
administration not from the Trump
administration nonetheless it is now
considered something deeply horrible to
say to people crossing the border and
claiming asylum
we need to adjudicate your claim and now
you have the option you can stay with
your kids in custody or you can make
sure that your kids are taken care of
with a family of Relation while you wait
for your turn but we are not going to
simply just say
you get to go free into the interior of
the United States how that is
unreasonable is absolutely beyond me but
according to the left this is the
equivalent of white supremacy so
Jonathan Chait who sometimes is an
intelligent human but is not in this
particular suite he tweeted out binary
as in like the binary choice that Trump
is providing binary is so grating what
about something softer like Sophie's
like Sophie's Choice how in the world is
it Sophie's choice to give people the
option of staying with their kids or
give them the option of putting their
kids with the government or with a
family member while they await their it
turn to be adjudicated for asylum how's
that like Sophie's Choice in any way
Sophie's Choice for those who have not
read the book or seen the movie is about
a mother in the Holocaust who was given
the choice as to which of her two
children she wants the Nazis to murder
that is not this that is not this and to
compare this to the Holocaust is
obviously silly and to make the
comparison in any way to the Holocaust
is obviously silly nobody is being
killed nobody is being told they have to
choose evil things happening to their
kids they're being told they can stay
with their kids I mean the also is worth
noting that Jews in Germany were
citizens of Europe these are people who
are crossing a border illegally to get
into the United States I do not remember
the Jews trying to get into the
concentration camps to you I remember
the Jews clamoring to get on the trains
these are people deliberately trying to
get into the United States and violating
American law in doing so I understand
the motivation I'd probably want a
better life too if I were living in
Honduras or El Salvador and my only
option were to try and cross through to
the United States illegally I'd probably
do the same thing that doesn't mean I
get to violate the laws of the country
and I would expect that the government
wants to process me and the government
would want to make sure that I'm not
released into the interior without them
actually adjudicating whether I'm full
of it when I claimed political asylum
but the overblown reaction of this is
really quite astonishing
Morgan Freedman is even worse so he is
going after Stephen Miller so Stephen
Miller is of course the president's very
tough on immigration adviser and I
disagree with Stephen Miller on a fair
bit of his immigration policy
particularly his view on the economics
of immigration he suggests that we
should cut down legal immigration to
because it's a threat to American jobs
and all of us I generally disagree with
that policy I just agree with Steve
approach to his kind of presentation in
public and all of that but the new play
by the left is to suggest that Steven
Miller is a white supremacist so Morgan
Freeman he says we are witnessing the
deliberate reincarnation of Adolf Hitler
right before our eyes and Steven Miller
will stop at nothing to preserve some BS
pure white bloodline we should be very
scared and must stop Trump from
empowering this evil and hatful man I
don't know how much how many hats
Stephen Miller has but I know that I'm
I'm deeply worried about people who have
too many hats I hate hey I hate hatful
people really despise it all so I'm
wondering what the deliberate
reincarnation of Adolph Hitler
looks like I mean is this like the boys
from Brazil the deliberate reincarnation
event not an overstatement at all Morgan
Freeman my goodness and then Ilhan Omar
sounds off like rabid anti-semite and
Jew hater Ilhan Omar she says Stephen
Miller who is Jewish is a white
nationalist the fact that he still has
influence on policy and political
appointments is an outrage says the
anti-semite who sits on the Foreign
Relations Committee and then Jason
Johnson on MSNBC he says well Stephen
Miller is all right he says Stephen
Miller is in control the policy and it's
not that we're trying to curb illegal
immigration it's that this is white
supremacy the news is it's going to get
worse well yeah because it's gonna be
Stephen Miller and his his his sort of
white nationalist tendencies are really
obvious you can't even dress that up as
I was just doing what I was told I mean
he goes back to relationships with
Richard Spencer and and they all write
in several different areas but but I
think even more disturbing is this idea
that Nielsen it wasn't just it was under
no circumstances fighting against us in
administration she was just trying to
find ways to smooth it down and cover it
with sugar and make it okay and that's
what makes it so disgusting
okay so this is such a wild
overstatement that this is based on
white supremacy as opposed to hey we
can't just have tens of thousands of
people flowing over the border without
us doing anything about it but
everything for the left becomes an issue
of racism now as I've said I don't like
how Steven Miller has publicly presented
I think his original travel ban as
written was stupid and counterproductive
and then they fixed it and then it
wasn't as stupid and counterproductive
but all of this said the media's rabid
approach to illegal immigration is truly
telling and I'll show you what the
actual agenda is in just one second
first we're
we're gonna be able to agree on
everything but I think we can all agree
we can all use more sleep getting a
great night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think you don't need
a new expensive mattress or sleeping
pills you just need to change your
sheets that's why you should check out
bowl and branch everything from bowl and
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft and they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store
Bolin brand sheets only a couple of
hundred bucks these are so comfortable I
got rid of all the other sheets in my
house I mean they really ruin sheets for
you because they are so good everyone
who tries Boleyn brand sheets loves them
including me that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews they are
so comfortable three former US
presidents sleep on bull and branch
sheets shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights if you don't love them
send them back for a refund I talk
you're gonna want to send them back
there's no risk and no reason not to
give them a try to get you started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
calm promo code Bend go to bull and
branch calm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets that is bol l and
branch calm promo code ban bowl and
branch calm and use that promo code ban
for 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets really really fantastic quality
sheets go check them out right now so
what is the real agenda here for a lot
of folks on the left I do not think that
it is the humane treatment of people
crossing the border if it were they
would be calling for more funding not
less funding for border patrol so we
could make sure that people who are
crossing the border and are taken into
border patrol custody are then being
kept in comfortable conditions along
with their children while their cases
are being adjudicated there'd be more
funding for the judiciary for these
border courts so that we could
accelerate the process and make sure
that everyone is heard more quickly
Democrats have turned all of this stuff
down instead what they want to do is
create a false scarcity in the border
patrol system so that they can then
claim that Trump is being cruel that is
the goal here to claim that cruelty is
the goal well again the goal would be to
enforce the law in the Trump and his
people haven't helped themselves because
there are all sorts of reports that have
been put out by the media that Trump
says that he wants to magnify family
separation as a deterrent for people who
are crossing the border and that of
course I have said over and over and
over is wrong but if cruelty if the
Democrats and people in media are
claiming that trumps cruelty is sort of
a feature not a bug of the system so too
is the democratic
which is deliberately robbing the CBP of
the support that they need in order to
make sure that the system is not cruel
but here's a Anderson Cooper calling
Trump cruel not the Democrats who are
withdrawing all the funding whether he
likes it or not has explicitly embraced
the notion of family separation the
cruelty it's not a bug of the system
it's a feature which may have been a
bridge too far for secretary Nielsen but
even if it was it comes to the end of a
very very long road which he has been
traveling for a very very long time okay
so it's a feature not a bug and
everybody who's involved is cruel and
brutal and terrible and awful and cruel
and brutal except for the Democrats who
refuse to fund this stuff except for the
Democrats who refused to fund this stuff
so their line is going to be that Trump
is being unethical and terrible Juan
Williams on Fox News tried to make the
same point the truth is that Obama was
dealing with unaccompanied minors here
you have families so you have moms and
children who were separated by Nielsen Y
again I think that it's not only is it
illegal it's unethical and immoral say
no in the suit like I'm just saying mom
now that were strangers it's just not
true what you said but I'm going to say
so it was working perfectly it wasn't
working we have a different kind of
issue now with so many families and
children why families okay so you can
hear Greg Gutfeld shouting over and over
why why and Juan Williams will not
answer the question because here is the
why Tom Perez head of the DNC explains
that he doesn't want a tough border
policy he thinks a tough border policy
is dumb he wants open borders okay
that's the real rationale here people in
the Democratic Party are using this as a
wedge issue to try and drive Hispanic
voters to the polls they want to portray
the Trump administration as cruel and
inhumane they want to increase the
number of people who potentially will be
given amnesty so they will vote Democrat
this is not about the humane treatment
of people crossing the border I want all
those people treated humanely so do you
everyone wants people who are entering
the country and legitimately have asylum
claims treated humanely I want them kept
in comfortable conditions while they
await the trial to which they are
entitled on their asylum claim and I
want people who are falsely claiming
asylum not to be able to enter the
country I want those people to go to the
back of the line and not cut the line
and I want those people to apply the
normal way and I
deep sympathy for people who are trying
to get into the country I am essentially
libertarian on immigration except for
two issues welfare use and cultural
assimilation I think the people who come
to the United States should assimilate
into traditional American values meaning
a belief in small government meaning a
belief that the government is not the
solution to everybody's problems meaning
a belief in free speech a belief in
private property right all of these sort
of anglo-saxon saxon notions of law i
think that everyone including my
great-grandparents had to come and
assimilate to those i think that is a
good thing i think that is piece number
one and piece number two you shouldn't
come here and be dependent on welfare
neither of those seem particularly
arguable to me you fulfill those two
conditions I think not only should we
welcome you in we should encourage you
to come I think all of that is good and
I want people who are trying to get in
treated well this is not about trying to
treat people with cruelty I don't want
kids separated from their parents either
I don't want any of that stuff but the
courts have made a standard that is not
enforceable other than for the President
to do nothing about illegal immigration
and that's precisely what Democrats want
here's Tom Perez from the DNC basically
just saying that out loud the notion
that this secretary who will live in
infamy who is now no longer there is
going to be replaced by someone that he
wants to be quote unquote tougher
they're losing sight of the point here
the the point is to be smarter when
you're smarter you're better when I keep
here and talk about tough tough doesn't
equal smart tough equals dumb and we
need to make sure we have smart law
enforcement that's how we can address
the challenges at the border tough
equals dumb I mean if that is not a
campaign ad for President Trump for 2020
I don't know what is legitimately tough
equals dumb so if you are tough on tens
of thousands of people entering the
border illegally and then falsely
claiming asylum then that's dumb that's
the real agenda here so you paint Trump
as cruel you use the federal courts to
knock down any policy he attempts to
pass you have Democrats stand out front
and rip on the cruelty while
simultaneously depriving the Border
Patrol and immigration and
naturalization and and depriving
Immigration and Customs Enforcement from
being able to take care of the people
crossing the border properly and then
you claim that you are just being
compassionate what a convenient
convenient thing for members of the
Democratic Party it is pretty
and is also deeply deeply dishonest but
I guess we're used to that at this point
from folks on the left when it comes to
the immigration decision now they are
constantly claiming that there is some
sort of secret there's some sort of
secret motivation behind Trump's policy
on immigration I don't know maybe there
maybe there is but I'll tell you this as
an American citizen who wants immigrants
treated humanely I also want to make
sure that people who come in the country
are not criminals are legitimately
claiming asylum under America's laws are
treated humanely and are and are not let
in willy-nilly and then just sent to the
middle of the country I don't see why
any of these things are mutually
exclusive and they shouldn't be
Democrats have made them mutually
exclusive the media have made them
mutually exclusive it's really bad stuff
okay coming up we're gonna talk about a
letter from Kyle Korver who's an NBA
player all about accepting his white
privilege and we'll talk about what's
right and what's wrong in the letter cuz
I think there's some actual interesting
complexity to the letter first you have
to go over to Daley wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
subscribe over at daily wire com1 you
know you get the rest of this show live
you get two additional hours every
afternoon of my show live which is
pretty great i mean we have terrific
guests on all the time senators
governor's experts on the issues members
of electoral bodies all sorts of great
people coming on the show routinely and
you get my analysis for two more hours a
day which is let me just say top notch
you get all of those things for $9.99 a
month or 499 dollars a year you get all
of that plus that's the greatest in
beverage vessels the leftist years how
to record tumblr you get access to our
Sunday special a day early you get extra
material from the Sunday special behind
the paywall you get to ask questions in
the conversation and sometimes during
the radio show breaks all sorts of good
stuff when you go and subscribe also
please subscribe over at youtube or
itunes when you do you get a lot of
great material also please leave us a
review we always appreciate it we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so meanwhile there's there's
this article that is getting all sorts
of play about a by a forward named Kyle
Korver who plays for the Utah Jazz
pretty good 3-point shooter and it's all
about how he is privileged he wrote it
for the players Tribune which is this
publication and that is it LeBron
James's publication I'm trying remember
whose publication it is and in case it
is it direct reader I can't remember in
any case the players Tribune is a place
where a lot of professional athletes
write about their thoughts Kyle Korver
has this piece that has been widely
distributed and shown as this is an
example of how white people should act
on the issue of race and so I think it's
worthwhile going through it because
there's some stuff here that's
meritorious and there are some stuff
here that is really not that's an
overreach of the situation and creates a
standard that is unfulfilled well so
here's what kyle korver writes he says
when the police break your teammates
like you'd think it would wake you up a
little when they arrest him on a New
York Street throw him in jail for the
night and leave him with the
season-ending injury you'd think it
would sink in you'd think you know there
was more to the story you'd think but
nope I still remember my reaction when I
first heard what had happened to Fabo
this is his teammate I'm to remember the
the teammates it was that Bosa foul aqus
I can I believe it was it was 2015 late
in the season
Fabo and I were teammates on the Hawks
and we'd flown into New York late after
a game in Atlanta when I woke up the
next morning our group our team group
text was going nuts details were still
hazy but guys were saying that will hurt
his leg during an arrest wait he spent
the night in jail everyone was pretty
upset and confused well almost everyone
my response was different I'm
embarrassed to admit it which is why I
want to share it with you today he said
that there were friends and he talked
about how they had hung out a lot he
said that when he found out the table
had been arrested his first reaction was
what was that boat doing out at a club
on a back-to-back not how's he doing not
what happens during the arrest not
something seems off with this story
nothing like that before I knew the full
story before I even had a chance to talk
to that boy I sort of blamed Thabo I
thought well if I'd been in that boys
shoes out of the club late at night the
police wouldn't have arrested me not
unless I was doing something wrong
cringe it's not like it was a conscious
thought it was pure reflex the first
thing to pop into my head and I was
worried about him no doubt but still
cringe it turns out that Fabo ended up
settling with the city of New York and
the NYPD he got like a four million
dollar settlement it fell away from the
news
bab-oh had surgery and went back through
rehab but he couldn't
his discomfort because his first
reaction was what was he doing out in a
club on a backpack well first of all
that's a legit question like why was he
out of the club why was your other
teammate also out of the club on it back
to back these two things are not
mutually exclusive you shouldn't be out
of the club on a back-to-back presumably
also there are racist police officers
who sometimes do racist things which it
appears is what happened in this case
although the police actually tried to
prosecute this player and suggest that
he resisted arrest and it is unclear
from all the surrounding evidence what
exactly happened nonetheless kyle korver
talks about this he says that when he
heard that Russell Westbrook Westbrook
and a fan exchanged words during a game
his initial reaction was you know
Russell Westbrook he gets into it with
the crowd a lot and then the full story
came out later what happened was that a
fan had said some really ugly things at
close range to Westbrook Westbrook had
responded after the game he said he'd
felt the comments were racially charged
the incident struck a nerve with our
team is what kyle korver writes in a
closed-door meeting with the president
of the Jazz the next day my teammates
shared stories of similar experiences
they'd had a feeling degraded in ways
that went beyond acceptable heckling one
teammate talked about how his mom had
called him right after the game
concerned for his safety in Salt Lake
City one teammate said the night felt
like being in a zoo one of the guys in
the meeting was stabbed oh my teammate
knew Tony I looked over him and
remembered his night in New York City
everyone was upset I was upset and
embarrassed too but there was another
emotion in the room that day one that
was harder to put a finger on it was
almost like disappointment mixed with
exhaustion
guys were just sick and tired of it all
he said this wasn't the first time
they'd taken part in conversations about
racing their NBA careers it wasn't the
first time they'd had to address the
hateful actions of others and one big
thing that got brought up a lot in the
meetings was how incidents like this
they weren't only about the people
directly involved they weren't about
Russ and some heckler it was about more
than that it was about what it means to
exist right now as a person of color in
a mostly white space it was about racism
in America he says before the meeting
ended I joined the team's demand for a
swift response and a promise from the
jazz organization that would it would
address the concerns we had so here is
the question
the first question when he says that
this was about racism in America when
there's a racist person who yells
something at a player at a basketball
game and then is ejected for the rest of
the season is that about racism in
America or is about a guy being a
jackass so there's a tendency on the
left to attribute every individual fault
to society at large if a person commits
a crime that's because society is
brutally it unequal
if a person is a racist that's because
society is deeply racist society is
always responsible for the actions of
the individual and you can see in this
piece
Korver trying to internalize that and
saying well I am part of society
therefore I am responsible for the
actions of this random racist fan even
though I think that the guy is a jackass
and even though I sided with the people
who are calling on him to be banned and
then he talks about how he has a guilt
that he simply cannot he cannot wash
away really I mean that's that's really
what he gets down to he says that
there's an elephant in the room I've
been thinking about a lot over these
last few weeks it's the fact that
demographically if we're being honest I
have more in common with the fans in the
crowd at your average NBA game then I
have with the players on the court which
there's nothing that you can do about
that I mean your race is unchangeable
he says I'm beginning to understand how
that means something I'm realizing no
matter how passionately I commit to
being an ally no matter how unwavering
my support is for NBA and WNBA players
of color I'm still in this conversation
from the privileged perspective of
opting into it which of course means
down the flip side I could just as
easily opt out of it every day I'm
giving that choice I'm granted that
privilege based on the color of my skin
I don't even know what that means
I mean legitimately I do not know what
that means what gives you the privilege
of opting out of a conversation on
racism it's the duty of every good
person to call out racism when they see
it so what where exactly do you get to
run away from it you will not be
victimized by racism in the same way a
black person will be that's true but
that's not the same thing as saying that
you simply get to opt out a good person
is good or bad not dependent on the
color of their skin here's where you get
into really dicey territory Korver says
in other words I can say every right
thing in the world I can voice my
solidarity with Russell Westbrook after
what happened in Utah I can involve my
position on what happened at that bow in
New York I can be that weird dude and
get out bragging about how he'd have
voted for Obama a third term I condemn I
can condemn every racist heckler I've
ever known but I can also fade into the
crowd and my face can blend in with the
faces of those hecklers anytime I want
well what no that's not right why are
you why are you the same as they are
you're an individual why would your face
blend in with the faces of the heckler
what makes the heckler the heckler is
the sound coming out of the face not the
face itself to attribute the thought to
the color is to slander an entire group
of people in which you are now claiming
membership he says I'm trying to ask
myself what I should actually do
how can i as a white man part of the
systemic problem become part of the
solution why are you part of the
problems did you do something he says I
have to listen I have to continue to
educate myself on the history of racism
in America well we should all do those
things but this part is where he gets
into basically I have to kowtow to the
politics of people who look different
than I do because I am not part of that
group I have to support leader this is
what he writes I have to support leaders
who see racial justice as fundamental as
something that's at the heart of nearly
every major issue in our country today
and I have to support policies that do
the same no you don't it depends on the
leaders and whether their ideas are good
why do you have to listen to everything
else Sharpton has to say because you
happen to be a different color from Al
Sharpton and the same color some people
who are racist you don't own the actions
of other white people just because you
happen to be white anymore then a Muslim
owns the actions of every radical Muslim
or a black person owns the actions of
every other black person right this is
this is self-imposed racial hierarchy
it's gross this is where you get into a
problem and and this is an Kyle Korver
then makes this point and this is the
point he's being praised far and wide
for and I don't think that it is a good
point he says two concepts I've been
thinking about a lot later our guilt and
responsibility when it comes to racism
in America I think guilt and
responsibility tend to be seen as more
or less the same thing but I'm beginning
to understand how there's a real
difference as white people are we guilty
of the sins of our forefathers no I
don't think so but are we responsible
for them yes I believe we are okay
explain so here's what Korver says I
guess I've come to realize that when we
talk about solutions to systemic racism
police reform workplace diversity
affirmative action better access to
health care even reparations it's not
about guilt it's not about pointing
fingers or passing blame it's about
responsibility it's about understanding
that when we've said the word equality
for generations what we've really meant
is equality for a certain group of
people
here's sloppy thinking and sloppy
writing he says about understanding when
we've said the word equality what we've
really meant is equality for a certain
group of people who's this week when
I've said the word equality I don't mean
for a certain group of people and
neither does Kyle Korver so now he's
actually merging back in guilt and
responsibility he is saying that we like
Kyle Korver today is responsible for 60
years ago somebody not meaning black
people when they talked about equality
he says it's about understanding
when we've said the word inequality for
generations what we've really meant is
slavery and its aftermath no I don't
believe that that's true when I've said
inequality I don't mean slavery and it's
aftermath so he he basically suggests
that the only way to be a woke person
the only way to fight racism is for
white people to shut up and then listen
to black activists and then suggest that
they are right on everything because we
could after all recede into the racist
background and you can see this manifest
in in Kyle Korver's recommended policy
so when he says that there's a
difference between guilt and
responsibility that of course is correct
I have a responsibility for my child and
that's not about guilt or innocence I
have a responsibility for people who
live in my community to help them out
that's why I give charity but that is
not the suggestion of slavery
reparations the suggestion of slavery
reparations is that I am guilty for a
sin of the past and therefore I owe
something to this person not as a fellow
citizen but for the sins of the past for
which I am somehow guilty this is why I
don't have any problem with folks on the
left talking about rectifying inequality
through government policy except that I
think that they are wrong I think it is
counterproductive I don't agree with the
principles undergirding their use of
government to do this thing but I don't
have a generalized problem with these
sort of left-leaning policy that says
that economic inequality requires
government intervention I don't disagree
to policy but the underlying motivation
at least I understand but I am NOT okay
with the slavery reparations
conversation that implies guilt for past
sins for white people for example
because now you're not separating people
based on wealth or non wealth now you
are separating people specifically based
on race and imputing responsibility and
guilt for actions to a group of people
who legitimately had nothing to do with
that thing that's why when you see
people like Cory Booker pushing an
investigation of slavery reparations he
can't explain what he would do with
slavery reparations no Democrat has
because they understand immediately that
other than their generalized government
policy they'd be pushing anyway there is
no way to do this without imputing guilt
to a certain group of people who are
actually not guilty for these actions so
where does Korver go with this in the
end he says I believe that what's
happening to people of color in this
country right now in 2019 is wrong
now you can believe that without
actually having to accept that you are
somehow a privileged member of society
in believing that by the way I think
that is worthwhile noting that in the
NBA the vast majority of players who are
earning millions of dollars are black
that is not an imputation of black
privilege that's because the NBA is a
meritocracy that has nothing to do with
racism
anyway Korver says the fact that black
Americans are more than five times as
likely to be incarcerated as white
Americans is wrong no the fact is not
wrong the fact is the fact unless you
can explain how that is a result of a
racist criminal justice system and which
people are innocent who are being put in
prison for no reason you got no basis
for saying that the fact is wrong the
fact that black Americans are more than
twice as likely to live in poverty as
white Americans is is wrong okay it's a
it's a fact I don't like but is it wrong
is it well depends where's the poverty
coming from if it is the result of a
historic injustice like Jim Crow
yes that's wrong and then we say okay
what is the best way to solve that but
if that if that poverty is coming from
you making a decision to have a baby out
of wedlock and not finish high school
the fact is the fact and the fact the
fact that black unemployment rates
nationally are double that of overall
unemployment rates is wrong again this
is Bernie Sanders talk where basically
any inequality is any inequity any
inequality is inequity any disparity is
discrimination and if you don't accept
that then you're not woke enough so at
least Kyle Korver got woke this is the
kind of language you see on college
campuses a lot and I don't happen to
think that it is a particularly useful
form of discourse we should all try to
understand the experiences of black
people in the United States of course we
should all try to think of each other as
brothers and sisters of course but this
basic notion that when you see a racist
heckler in the crowd that you somehow
have a shared commonality with the
racist heckler more than you do with the
person being heckled that is you
breaking yourself down into a person who
is a member of a group by dint of color
as opposed to you being an individual
who gets to make your own decisions in
life about how you wish to act obviously
Kyle Korver has much more in common with
the NBA player who is black standing
next to him on the court than the white
heckler in the crowd obviously and this
notion that he could choose to just fade
away
he just that's true and that would be
immoral that's why morality is not
dependent on your group identity okay
time for some things I like and then
some things that I hate so things I like
my wife has been staying up
extraordinarily late watching the show
on Amazon called the widow with Kate
Beckinsale the show is really good it's
it's sort of an action drama mystery
thriller battle plays this woman whose
husband allegedly dies in a plane crash
she didn't actually die in the plane
crash and she finds out a few years
later he did not die so where's he been
all the time why didn't call her that's
the premise of the show here's a little
bit of the preview hey I look to
something in the glove compartment
did you happy anniversary
giorgia you really need to forget about
okay so the show is good it's got a
bunch of good at Kate Beckinsale is
actually quite good in the show almost
good enough to make me forgive her for
dating Pete Davidson no okay okay it's
just a joke I she can date whoever she
wants obviously even if the person
happens to be a generation younger than
her and and it's a weird pairing and
then again it is a puzzling puzzling
thing to every to every human who is
who's watching in any case the show is
really good and worth checking out so go
check that out right now okay now a
bunch of things that I hate okay so the
thing that I hate number one there's a
restaurant that is now being raked over
the coals by Yelp reviewers there's a
woman who is white and she opened a
Chinese food restaurant called Lucky
Li's in New York City and she is and and
this was tweeted out by some activist
named Melania Olmstead tweeted wow wow
wow this white woman picture just opened
a clean the Chinese food restaurant in
New York City called Bucky Lee's not
only is she using Chinese food
stereotypes naming she is shaming
traditional Chinese food cooking with
msg grease and starch she is not woken
up you see because she called her
restaurant a Chinese name because it is
a Chinese restaurant what she couldn't
call it Bob's
Bob's the Chinese food restaurant of
course she is using a Chinese name to
demonstrate that it like if somebody
opened a deli if somebody opened to deli
and their last name happened to be Smith
I wouldn't expect them to call it
Smith's deli if they called it Stein's I
wouldn't be like oh cultural
appropriation that's so terrible oh my
god they're trying to convey that it's a
Jewish style belly like what so this
this lady has now been hit by crazy Yelp
reviews hashtag Asian stereotype first
close the doors this is offensive on so
many levels so that everybody is going
after this woman they're saying love to
watch Becky go bankrupt for racist
appropriation so also I'm confused are
we supposed to be in favor of MSG or
against MSG so I guess when Chinese
people use msg and their cooking then
it's good and traditional when white
people don't use msg then that becomes
cultural stereotyping this is
nonsense we're not gonna be able to live
in a society like this my friend and you
know tweeted out my family in Asia can't
believe that there are people in the US
who think like this the explanation
sounded so stupid in Vietnamese they
thought I had missed translated what
happened on Q online slacktivism
descended on the businesses Yelp page so
gross guys I mean honestly get a life
get a life and meanwhile other things
that I hate so Bernie Sanders is ripping
on Fox News again he says that Fox News
is a propaganda outlet I will give it to
Murray I mean Bernie is obviously acting
like a front-runner here he actually he
is the only Nixon can go to China and
only Bernie can go to Fox News so he's
gonna do a town hall on Fox News which
honestly it's kind of it's kind of
Awesome like good for him I've offered
to to have a discussion or debate with
Bernie Sanders many many times he's
never done anything like this but going
into hostile territory he's right he
figures that if he gets relaxed by the
Fox News host he can go and complain to
his base and they'll be happy with him
and if he does a great job then he ends
up with a big win he's acting like the
front-runner if Biden going on Fox News
he'd be hit by the online left for
presumably being too conciliatory toward
the right here's Bernie Sanders though
slandering Fox News as a propaganda
outlet while proclaiming he will appear
on it nonetheless
well better or for worse and it is for
worse for whatever reason you know Fox
has a huge viewing audience and to
simply say that we're not going to talk
to millions of people who watch that
Network I don't think is smart when I go
on Fox what I will say is look many of
you voted for Donald Trump but he lied
to you
how do you explain that the people who
voted for Trump if you don't talk the
people voted for Trump working people
need to know the truth and that is the
Donald Trump we trained him lied to them
and I intend to do that okay so he was
wrong about all of these things but you
know it is amazing how he and many
members of the left will call Fox News a
propaganda a well appearing on a place
like MSNBC okay final thing that I hate
so New York has now had to declare a
health emergency over a measles outbreak
because there are too many people
getting the measles they've ordered
mandatory vaccinations for people
exposed to the virus because measles
does in fact kill people and it had been
basically eliminated into the United
States thanks to vaccination and then
thanks to people who are sometimes it's
religious people sometimes it is secular
left us to like essential oils and have
bought into all this nonsense about
vaccinations vaccinate your kids guys
I mean legitimately vaccinated vaccinate
your kids the the supposed evidence
linking vaccinations to autism is a
bunch of hooey and the fact that we have
gotten rid of diseases that have plagued
humanity for legitimately thousands of
years and that we are now seeing those
diseases rise again is a pretty terrible
thing vaccinate your kids please alright
so we'll be back here a little bit later
today with a couple more hours of
content for you if you're a subscriber
you get it if you don't then well tough
and then we'll see you back here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show as the 2020 Democrat
presidential primary race heats up one
issue takes center stage B s we will
analyze BS from the campaign trail to
the mainstream media check it out of
daily wire calm